chuck i got a question for you
okay uh how many stars can you see
with the naked eye on a perfect night on
a mountaintop
no clouds just pick a number
billionaires and billions
uh you know gary larson had a comic
where the caption
gary larson you know yet the caption was
carl sagan as a child
and he's looking up and he said there's
so many stars there must be hundreds of
i know that's funny hundreds hundreds
and hundreds of them
so um so dude i don't wha i'm i mean
seriously
if you're in a really like like when uh
where i
where i went to summer camp and it was
on top of a mountain camp sky mount
okay and it was in the summer with the i
mean
when you would look up it seemed like
millions of stars
and campers talk about laying out on
their sleeping bag looking up
of course if you're camping you're not
in the city or somewhere far away from
the city
so there's no city lights probably
there's no pollution and campers talk
about
you know just being able to reach out
and touch the stars and grab them
so on any given night
if you have good vision and you're
looking up
and there's no moon you can see about
three thousand stars
what i'm just telling you don't shoot
the messenger
okay come on three thousand lousy stars
and if that's just in half the sky the
other half there's another three
thousand the part that hasn't risen yet
or will never rise because you gotta be
in the southern hemisphere for it
so the total number of stars that are
brighter than the detection threshold of
your
human eye and the retina is about six
thousand
it's only six thousand that sucks and so
i didn't ask you to get emotional about
it this is well you know
information chuck because it because
that is so okay let's that's so
less romantic than looking up and and
just like the millions of stars in the
comments
all here just for me that's not like
okay so now watch let's keep going
so now let's introduce the moon
right all right so the moon has light
reflected light from the sun
right which by the way thousands of
years ago people thought the moon had
its own light
they didn't really think that through um
but as before science the methods and
tools of science were brought to bear
on such questions but so then see now
now
see now you got me because now i want to
know what happened
to let someone know that it was actually
a reflection of the sun
as opposed to being just its own
luminosity
well so i don't know if there's an exact
moment but if you go back to biblical
genesis where it says god made two great
lights
one to light the day and the other to
light the night this is very
sort of they're making their own light
you know that's the that's the only
sensible way to interpret
that sentence and then you assign the
moon to the night and the sun to the
daytime
as though they are their own agencies
all right so um but once you realize
that the moon goes around the earth and
the earth and the moon go around the sun
there's no other way to
understand and then you get the phases
come out for free out of that
right okay so you bring out the moon
there's only one phase of the moon that
rises at sunset
and sets at sunrise okay why is that
sunset
and and therefore it's up all night
and that's the phase of the moon that's
exactly opposite the sun
okay okay so what phase would that be
it's got to be a floor
that's a full moon right any other phase
is rising at setting at some other time
of day and night
right so let's take a full moon night
because that's up all night
the moon makes so much light that the
number of stars you see in the night sky
drops
because it changes it washes out the low
threshold of what you're able to detect
so when a full moon comes out
the 3000 drops to about 300.
oh my goodness about 300. that that's
that's
that's awful it's it's sad it's so this
the moon is just stealing all these all
the stars glory
all the stars glory and it's so if you
have a friend who's an astronomer who's
ready to go out
never say oh i hope your moon is bright
and you're it's like
yeah that's like screw you buddy have a
really lousy
like stargazing we are it's a
it's a not very hidden secret that
astronomers
hate the moon we hate the moon
when you apply for observing time at
telescopes okay
and it's competitively awarded there's
dark time
and there's bright time all right and
the bright time is sort of relegated
to like if you have a bright scrub
scientist
if you're like a scrub scientist then
you get bright time
you know what i mean it is the it is the
least coveted
time right i have a very uh clever
colleague uh i knew him at princeton
when i was there
and he applied for time at one of the
caltech back when he was at caltech
at one of the caltech telescopes and
he's
his favorite objects are very deep sky
faraway galaxies all right that you
would never see during bright time
he applied for time during bright time
okay
and and of course he got it because
there was a very low demand for that
time but people why did he do that what
what
and and they said well you know where
where is he right name is jim gunn
where is jim gunn tonight oh he's at the
telescope and then you wait around and
you
watch and then
that night was a total lunar eclipse
so he my boy knew him he
knew what he was doing right and so
the full moon goes away and he has you
know a couple of hours of
really good observing time at when
otherwise people are
avoiding it but so anyhow so there's not
that many stars so if you
whip out a pair of binoculars even
simple ones
that number goes up okay and generally
the bigger
the the the lens okay
the the size of the lens is
is is capturing light from the sky and
so
anything that's bigger than the pupil of
your eye is going to
see more is going to bring more
starlight to you than your eyes alone
that's why even simple binoculars will
up that number from three thousand to
ten thousand
to a hundred thousand then you get
honkering binoculars that you
basically you take it to millions and so
yeah so it doesn't take much to improve
on the human eye this
basically improves your eyesight and
then you can see
much farther away objects okay so the
real
the real moral of this story
is does this have a moral yeah a
chocolate i don't want yes i don't want
to imbue my stuff here
with okay because morrow is the wrong
because
mauro uh uh connotes that
something um a lesson for you a lesson
for life exactly a lesson to live by
would be okay so uh but the
i think the real takeaway here is that
human beings have lousy eyes
that's that's the thanksgiving
should be the name of this segment it's
our most cherished
uh sense right because it is it brings
in information from the farthest
distances
relative to your other senses so it
understandably has great value
it also has great value in the history
of evolution
because sight has developed in multiple
ways at multiple times
separate from each other and from one
another so if it's so
important then why is our eyesight so
doggone
loudly no it's good to know if the
tiger's chasing you
that's what you need wait get out of
here what is that out here
you hear it and then you look i'm
running the other way
right but i'm saying if you couldn't see
you'd just be standing there going what
is that i hear oh
if you couldn't see it right right right
so you wouldn't be able to know it at a
distance
and then and then run you you'll be much
closer perhaps
the sense of smell goes to great
distances but it doesn't leave the air
right right you can see through a vacuum
and so
so our sense of sight understandably is
highly
valued um but i'm just saying
that you don't have to know that there
are millions of stars in the night sky
for your survival so there was no
evolutionary pressure to build our eyes
to be
even better than what they are that's
all i'm saying gotcha yeah
and that makes perfect that makes
perfect right so you can't totally blame
god for that
right so uh but the fact is though it's
still far less romantic to think that
there are
3 000 lousy stars up there and then on a
full moon there's only 300 it's like
nobody even came to the concert
so now if you're really geeky okay and
i've done this many times
if you're really geeky your fist at
arm's length
held up to the sky spans 10 degrees
okay okay so one way to test this is you
stick your fist out
at arm's length and put your bottom of
your fist on the horizon
then put another fist on top and on top
like you're climbing a rope and you keep
doing this
and then when you get straight up it
should be nine fists so
90 degrees from horizon to the top
okay now you might say well suppose
somebody has like really big hands right
ask it what what if somebody has really
big hands they generally have long arms
ah that would make the difference let's
make the difference so right this is one
of these ratios that is
relatively constant for humans your fist
at arm's length but it does not work for
orangutan
yeah if you have a high ape index that's
a problem
exactly if your knuckles have to track
you are dragging on the ground
why are my measurements always off
i can never get the right message so you
just got to go to the other page we have
the ape
rules rather than the human rule
so here's what you do so take your fist
your fist
you know my fist is 10 degrees top to
bottom and maybe 8 degrees left and
right but
that doesn't matter for this exercise
call it 10 by 10.
okay okay so your fist at arm's length
in the sky
blocks 10 by 10 degrees
which is 100 square degrees right okay
100 square degrees here's what you do
find any random spot on the sky
put your fist up and then move your fist
aside and count
how many stars you're blocking okay just
count it
okay all right i know how many square
degrees there are on the sky
there's 42 253 square degrees
in the entire sky wow okay
if i last i did my math correctly it's
it's like trig math to get that right
okay so because it's spherical it's a
spherical thing and you it's squares and
but anyhow for about 42 000 square
degrees so
how many hundred square degrees are in
42 000 square degrees
there is uh 420 square degrees
up 420 patches of 100 square degrees
right okay so get your number
multiplied by 400.
and you should come up with about 6 000.
plus or minus of course
and i've done this many times it bears
out wow
i'm telling you that i'm not gonna do
that
okay
i'm i'm gonna sit there and look at the
stars i'm not gonna do that i'm not
doing that
and i want to say i'm disappointed chuck
but it's just i i i
that is too geeky even for me man
[Laughter]
i'm down i'm down for the telescope i'm
down for the stargazing
i'm down for the laser pointer i'm down
for seeing what constellations all right
one last thing
one last thing but once once you start
getting you know to making you calculate
40 000 degrees okay all right
all right so um
so let me leave you with a positive note
okay okay all right all right here you
go
um the farthest object visible
to the unaided eye is a galaxy
beyond the stars of the constellation
andromeda
so you find a drama in the sky and
there's stars and then there's like a
fuzzy patch
right okay the stars you see are just
sitting on our nose in our own galaxy
the milky way
the fuzzy patch is well beyond this two
million light years away wow
okay you can see it because there's so
many stars
there and the light is but you can't
resolve it so it's just a puddle
of light in fact it wasn't until 1920.
no 1926
that edwin hubble the man not the
telescope
put his telescope on this fuzzy patch
and resolved it into stars
wow okay so before then people just
called it a nebula it was like the
andromeda nebula they thought it was
just a fuzzy cloud
so that this is why what things look
like to you aren't always what they are
all right so he does this and you
realize it's an entire other galaxy
that galaxy is visible to the naked eye
so that galaxy has
200 400 billion stars in it
right so if you want to if you want to
think differently about what the human
eye can see you take your 3 000
that are in our galaxy up there and then
add to it the hundreds of billions
in the andromeda galaxy which you can
also see wow look at that and in that
case when you look up
if you include the andromeda galaxy in
your field of view you get to say you're
seeing billions of stars again
billions and billions billions of
problems solved
problem solved so there you go chuck
that's fascinating that's great i don't
know if you ever thought about how many
stars you see at the night sky but
that's kind of more than you ever
cared to know about it yeah well you
know i don't here's the thing
i don't have to think about it anymore
so there it is another explainer video
from the universe
and from star talk all right
we're done here uh this is star talk
chuck always good to have you
always good to be here
you